okay four people joining our live stream
we are talking about machine learning
functionality for the upcoming version
of Wolfram language and we are I hope in
the late stages of dealing with a budget
on supervised machine learning functions
yes okay
I sing imputation their names for
missing imputation yeah I mean I do not
like the name imputation I think it
sounds accusatory um and the default
thing that we are how are we default lis
specifying the data which is considered
to be missing with amazing single with
the symbol with the actual symbol
missing yes okay with some possibility
presumably in the function to say this
is what I want you to consider to be
missing by green screen types well this
we didn't completely decide but yeah
that could be one way of specifying
missing actually that one isn't meeting
we kind of agreed to use what was it I
am missing that a token okay yes so to
be an option missing that a token or or
was it with a rule after the data say
look a missing data token okay by the
way somebody on our live stream is
saying they're hoping this is about the
next iteration of the neural net
framework unfortunately this is not
about uses of it maybe we'll live stream
the discussions about the what's going
on with a neural net framework it's
quite it quite interesting um actually
there's on Friday I'm seeing on my
calendar 3:30 Eastern is supposed to be
something about that and maybe we'll
have a chance to livestream that oh boy
we've got a lot of these meetings coming
up um and uh whoever thinks that people
are on here looking at the calendar
whoever thinks that the text cases
meetings gonna happen 11:00 a.m. Eastern
on Friday is wrong it's got to be
an hour or two after that um anyway all
right so should we set in stone they're
missing get a token an option that's
because we got to have a name for the
actual function okay this is a thing
okay it's another thing but right to
specify the missing value we agreeing
that there's an option what the name of
the option is we're not sure um and
shadi is shadi on the school yes okay so
do you need I mean for image processing
and so on and for audio and such like
you also need to kind of some kind of
missing do you need the notion of a
missing data token that could be for
example some shade of cyan for a green
screen or something
that make any sense for example for in
paint
how are you specifying so for in paint
you're giving a mask that says where the
data should be considered to be missing
correct correct that's always it has
always been a separate image okay but so
you could imagine a version of in paint
where you say whenever the thing is this
color in paint they're correct
I think it's a different way of
specifying a mask so we have that now
with colors near and so on
so what will it remind me how that works
for the case of so you're saying um
okay so you're unlikely to have a very
crisp color you know but you know colors
new what what is that what is that
called color detect
no I mean I mean what are you saying
come no I
what are you after what a monster is how
do you turn everything that's near blue
into something else
color detect that scent new and 12 what
is it price color or detect I'm
surprised you don't have it
this is the head branch built
right it's in prototype okay okay I can
start that just for a second but so then
what how does that work there is a rathp
age for that as well but you would say
color detect image comma cyan and then
it will give you a mask could be a
binary or grayscale mask with all the
pixels near Sian but didn't we have a
function we didn't we define a notion of
we talked about functions colors within
a certain distance of such let's say
Allah okay so colors near okay so we
have colors it was called color
neighborhood but we read you you know
you came up with a certain name okay so
colors near red so we can say something
like image replace so let's imagine that
we have recolor image image of US flag
for example come on what's this doing
yeah there we go
okay um okay so then what we say here if
we want to replace the red there so what
would we say imagery color
I mean recolor okay that's another new
function coming okay of that image okay
so colors near red goes to green for
example correct and that red is probably
too
far from their birthday let's say I say
point two or something what does that
mean I mean that should be that number
should be oh well okay
so that point two I would imagine to be
distance across the color across color
space correct how can it need point five
for that red the RGB one zero zero is
fairly far from that red we also have we
have also added fine matching color
another function that you can give it
the image and say red it will give you
this shade of the red alright okay but
so so for in paint for example um I
don't want attract but I just wanted to
do one comment on this maybe maybe would
want to do a bit of clustering maybe
sometimes you want to like I consider
the flag you still have some lines of
red that I would probably be darker
yellow and I don't know the intuition
would be here is an image I want things
that are close to red maybe we can
actually use this image to figure out
what its close to red rather than adding
a hard limit I don't disagree with that
idea
right we don't have a hard limit to we
have some smoothing going on but
probably that's that's still too far
okay fine okay so the point I was going
to make about in paint is right now if I
said in paint to this flag right with
the only way I would do that I could
imagine saying in paint that flag for
every colors knit for all the colors
near red I'm saying right which won't
work right now but that would be
treating like missing data anything near
red effectively right okay in 12 if you
do color detect a right if you add a
color detect around that color in the
air well you would need the image again
as well yeah okay so color detect did we
agree on that name yes it's like edge
detect right okay so now I do that and
it'll be a very exciting flag I don't
know why it yeah why it in painted
everything maybe color detect is using a
different distance function in colors
near I'll look into that
but practically this should give you the
same just just right just run color
detect and see what mass comes out
well that's it everything masks who
knows that's really weird that doesn't
make sense
image recolor didn't recolor the things
oh I see I see I see those are stripes
image recolor didn't recolor at point
two they're using functions know that
they're just using two different
distance functions we all we have to
make those consistent okay all right
okay fine so this will now in paint yeah
okay fine but weird but okay fair enough
um okay so back to the missing
imputation stuff okay um okay so the
idea is we are filling in data that is
considered missing now notice that in
paint
what is the second argument for for any
of these missing imputation functions if
it isn't above so missing imputation so
an argument can only view property you
can give new data it's free about either
getting a van in pewter function or
getting out the imputed data and you can
have both if you want by putting a list
of property as in an argument
so input a function you just use it
right on the data and the missing
imputes that the one that you can either
just give data to be missing or you can
give let's say learn distribution of the
first argument and then the data to be
seeing all built-in distribution as if
as valuing that we won't have why do we
even need that first argument if the
data is an image then this is what you
want to assume right okay yes that's as
opposed to self learning oh yeah much
better transfer learn from a big big
dead horse of course so that's okay
that's a very interesting conversation
right now the way it is said
it's a purely self learned function when
we'll have built-in feature extractor
which are complex because you have to be
reversible actually yeah actually it
will be a bit complex because we cannot
just anyway transform the missing and
impute in some teachers page and then go
back we have to do some more complex so
it may be slow very slow stuff but
nevertheless when we have these things
then we can add a mix of a lot of prior
knowledge so to speak about imagine
whatever and things that we learn it's
in a better hybrid I don't know if we
and we have the same in feature
extraction that a synthetic fert about
also learns from the data so don't you
want to continue in this direction
what does literal extraction and we are
picture extract you just give it the
data or you give it a prior to a prior
set of things and the data right like
this yes you can get a feature
extraction method yeah sort of
you can do face features image feature
so you can specify this in football why
do you put that in the argument
structure it's it's so good argument
let's see I mean let's look at
documentation the documentation is
broken for this okay so you're saying
feature extraction it's a second
argument second argument you can put a
named extract tour or extraction method
which okay and which you can see the
list if you open it is an option but
even in automatic mode or you just put
example what they will do is use some
built in but then learn on top of that
as well we
might be confusing for the users because
let's say you put the same image 100
times it's not the same as if you put
just one image and actually if you put
the same 800 times it will reduce
dimension to just one number because it
will say well there's no there's no
signal in these data it's all the same
stuff and that I think can be confusing
for some user if you have repeated data
a certainly you know it's quite of a
different behavior so I can imagine a
user that doesn't just want to fill in
missing data
but that doesn't know about machine
learning doesn't want to know what
machine learning is even just want the
thing to work let's say the repeated
data this is the kind of worms I mean
this is basically saying you know these
okay realistically how useful is the
self learning stuff is it useful or is
it kind of chronic very useful very
useful so all that assets are different
basically I mean okay I understand so
like anomaly detection clearly self
learning is useful for anomaly detection
yes it's like your data there's for
anomalies or your title it's impute
missing values now for the case I mean
it's really concerned the case of images
text and sound right which is kind of
this Universal data sets you might
expect people to impute the email or the
sound or the text you know and without
learning anything and I can see some
essentially what in painters I mean in
this exactly it's basically the the
analog of impute missing impute for
images so let's talk about that for a
second okay what is the outlook of that
for audio maybe it's its own function
shoddy
do you have an analogue of that I mean
in other words now if there's audio but
there are mmm in in in sort of signal
processing when you think of more smooth
smooth signals yes they you know a
typical scheme used is that you have a
model for a signal right and then you
yeah we just what used for for this but
it's basically what's going on in this
missing imputation here too but they're
just simpler you know you have you know
kind of like LP linear predictive coding
and stuff like that stuff like that yes
exactly
um but you know but it's - when you use
the signal on both sides let's say you
have a gap in the signal then you got to
use to smoother you have to predict from
both ends so to speak you have to use
the information on both sides in the
case of audio it's like scratch removal
same as with images in some sense well
Scott yeah and it's still called in pain
local or people refer to that as in
painting as well I don't know what are
their terms has been used I see so how
does I'm sorry it is in paint have a
default second argument yeah okay so in
principle in paint could have a default
second argument right Paul MP in paint
could do anomaly detection to find out
what things seemed like they were
anomalies in the picture I mean this
will be more denoising or error
corrections would be another function I
think
opposed to missing imputation yes so are
you saying that missing imputation well
okay fine but isn't that what we want to
do I mean the audio case where you fill
in
the missing what was it you know and the
Watergate tapes or something you know I
forget what that was you fill in the
missing whatever using missing
imputation that's pretty silly
I mean I don't see it being used for
audio do you and that's so much um major
be the main and I don't know if text
Thanks can it be used with text you
wrote something that's obviously a
missing word and we impute
right that's a different and exotic
piece of functionality that sounds very
yes error correction is more the type
organizing of text in a way is more very
useful function so it's what is
denoising of text what are you talking
about
your correction you mean spell
correction for example yeah I mean spell
grandma you know I mean those are
different and very exotic functions that
really that that are built from the
corpus of you know you know spelling is
a societal construct so to speak built
from the corpus of all all words
spelling nots built from your individual
corpus probably I mean in other words
from your individual corpus you might
have misspelled the word commitment or
something you know all through your
documents you don't really want it to
self learn from that document and decide
that's a new word I mean you can do that
for a new language but but it's true
that this function are more useful in
more classic data yes like yeah so what
we're concluding more or less is if you
want inpainting use in paint and so that
this function here is mostly filling in
missing data that something else
something else indicates that it's
missing
you know you've tried tokens and other
ways to point out what characterize is
missing right well the concept here is
that there's a missing data token where
the default is basically uh you know
underscore missing correct that that's
your concept here yeah yes the default
is just missing right
so which kind of elevates missing which
we want to do anyway um you know
unfortunately we're gonna end up with a
calculus of missing data as we as we
perfectly well know like you know are
three missings
you know if you take the mean of some
data and it's got missings in it how do
you handle the missings and so on um in
determinate does that well
actually internally in the machine
learning code we use any terminate
extensively instead of missing because
it has these properties doesn't
determinant work would mean correctly I
think so think that that should come out
as indeterminate
you get poisons computation yeah I mean
it could remove those have a name that K
like low so but no but that's the point
it's not doing that I mean what we need
is a calculus of missings where I mean
what do we think that should come out as
one two three
you know mean of one two three missing
missing I think it should come out of
the mean of one two three
yeah you're right it's a little bit I
mean many case it would be the same as n
terminates in some K is not so in that
case not right in this case it's really
but is nothing you know what nothing is
nothing is oh yeah it's a very useful
thing which is okay um all right so
let's come back here to the name of this
so let's explain what it is that it does
again so it fills in missing data Frank
yeah for the verb version missing
include missing filled fill missing that
I impute whatever I want to call it this
you know the word impute is just not a
winner in my book who was not an okay as
a native English speaker I know what
that word means but it is it has a sense
of accusation for the non-native English
because did you even know what the word
meant yeah yeah you're well it you have
I think we have that seem you know in
French I think that's something
different in French who knows then then
okay so I just don't think it's a winner
of a word um all right I I well here is
one vote I looked it up first time I saw
okay and use the accusation version
including missing data this I didn't
know as well before okay fine so this
what this was
loser but on the other hand it keeps its
into the realm of machine learning I'm
just scared of a misuse in the same what
we had for me future extract how many
times you said we mail about why doesn't
feature extract work for one image you
know or things like that and because it
kind of the name give the wrong
expression that it's not a learning
function what actually it is a learning
function so maybe calling a name little
bit more obscure will keep it in the
realm of statistics and machine learning
and people understand okay so do it
yourself thing to do it yourself thing
it's not a you know but it's something
it's it's a very nice you know package
thing I mean if your argument is let's
give it an obscure name so nobody knows
to use it a bit self-defeating I agree
just it's not plugging plates I mean
it's plug-and-play in a way but still do
it yourself you have to give your data
it's bring your later type function
right okay and you're right that it
shouldn't give a sense in which I mean
it is a statistical know what what does
it really mean it is kind of a a
statistical you know filling in of
missing data yeah I mean let's see what
kind of example you know they can't you
know so we sort of logic puzzle where
you are 2 4 8 16 and the I am right
right I mean the word inferred
you
might be I mean because that's what's
happening it's inferring from the data
that you have information value
and for a missing
hmm Robert it's filling in the missing
so that's what we want to do I mean it's
it's replacing missing it's replacing
missing values with inferred values with
statistically inferred values well with
machine learning inferred values
yeah I should give her I don't know if
we ever gave a short demonstration sure
give a short demonstration little mini
prepared for for 30 seconds okay I can
find a nice that I said alright but but
that's that's some I mean the to infer
missing values I believe that would
people would understand what that means
infer yeah
um
okay what would if we use that form what
would these different functions be
called so one would be called missing
value inference function oh that's ya
know what never gonna type it yeah um
and then what would some of these always
be called so if you don't even eat value
sort of inference function so there
would be the missing in France missing
in France would be the one that returns
the missing inference function or
missing in for our function if we wants
to be it's weird but if you want to be
consistent with the other ones provide
learning functions I see that one would
be missing value infer all were just
said maybe without the value I don't
know like missing yeah
or missing and further a function we
still put function with okay
singing friends and family sing went
missing inference is which one and then
this is the one that returns the missing
in for a function and in family sync is
the one that acts on the data have we
ever had to do that in other cases where
we flip around no no I didn't so it will
be missing infer if we want to be
consistently missing infer
like yeah a dimensional reuse or feature
extract it's better than impute it's a
lot better than impute in my opinion so
missing and fir in this case would take
the data and it would try to remove
missings by inferring um you know
attempts to infer from the data how to
replace how to fill in missing values is
that correct yes and it'll actually more
accurately fills and missing values by
inferring them from the data from us by
inferring them from the structure of the
data yes yes and in practice it models
the data which distribution and use that
to sample actually I think I'm ready if
you want to algorithm fills in I'm just
trying to get what we would call this
missing and fir I don't really like
missing infer and that sentence is just
missing infer is just totally weird but
it doesn't say what it does I mean the
fact is information values says what it
does
well wait what's wrong with that name
well then what do we call missing
inference which is producing a function
note yes so let's imagine that this one
was called missing value inference
function
but that's the only thing it that
missing in France it builds the
distribution right and creates the
function that can then simulate and
infer well yes and
you
why do we have to have separate
functions even so there may be a second
argument that says you know what the
hell it does
well the problem with that is that
what's happened here and we could get
around that in this case because we
don't actually believe that prior
distribution is all that interesting
here we believe most of the time you're
going to be self learning yes one way to
use distribution you already learn for
all the reason for example well okay but
so here's a possible possibility so
let's say we said infer missing values
and what you've got is pure data so we
could have you know prior distribution
arrow and then your data if you wanted
that case or you could say infer missing
values of just data like that and these
would return okay so this
return the data how common is it going
to be to want to generate let me see him
critter yeah and why is it different why
is it missing impute are different from
a learn distribution potentially we
could use non distribution and I can
know how to impute as well but it's true
that we will at least 412 it will be
only learn distribution we manage all
non learn distribution ways to make them
fit into distribution type things for
now so it so that what difference is
there between simply saying learn
distribution of the data of some prior
data and then feeding that in as the
prior for infer missing values and why
do we ever need a missing and puter
function so okay for two reason or many
needs so it sure at the moment there's
no much difference but the first reason
is what I said just before we could have
all the method that do not learn the
distribution why not something that is
faster and I don't know the second
reason is that you declaring your
intention of inferring missing values
when learning the distribution and we
can use that there's a method that are
very good that let's say generating new
data so data is in data but not good at
inferring missing values so at the
moment all our methods are quite generic
but as soon as we start adding more
powerful method that will become
specialized this one is good at imputing
this Way's we are generating this one is
good at scoring the PDF so for anomaly
detection okay so what we need is is you
want somehow instead of that prior being
a learned distribution you want that
prior to be something that is more
specific to this and and in fact your
missing and puter function would have to
be given a whole new data set I mean
unlike classifier function which is
given a single element and is told
classify it this is basically a big data
set to dataset transformer it can be a
single element as well no this one I
mean yeah you can either one example are
many examples and it just use the
distribution learn before to include
okay so the issue is okay so you know
what I my claim is gonna be that this
should be part of learn distribution
that is that learn distribution should
have some advisory options that say you
know this is going to be used for
missing imputation that could be one
thing still let's imagine you have your
data set I mean we need at least okay
maybe we don't need all this function
okay it's just about missing in about
the inference one that you don't want
yeah I'm trying to see whether we can
just get away with one function here and
fir missing values which I lose name I
like a lot actually that that could be
right and that could be right let's see
I mean as long as we don't have our
methods that don't use land street
schon right but I'm even saying if if
you and then we need this option so it's
kind of a goal to learn distribution
task goal analytically yeah right
exactly
optimize it for this that that could be
but I do want that I do the
demonstration so my yes although I think
I'm pretty how do this I think this is
climb I think in infer missing values as
a function people will actually use as
opposed to imputation whether I'll just
feel that somebody's being accused of
something all right let's see the quick
demo a little bit running out of time
but let's see the first go for it
so it's funny with anything look so it's
just really England distribution
actually so here I have some data ok
just by eventual title so we can see
what's going on in sledding the
distribution and you can by the way see
some information about the distribution
she wants
let's see I don't know them I Griffin
that I've been tested and so on and this
is a contour plot that will show the PDF
of these things along with the data such
as you get an idea and actually this is
an internal function we use right now
something like impute first document
distribution then you put the date time
with some missing so here the X is 7 and
why is missing so it should be something
in this area right and it's missing by
sampling and I'm sorry sorry-sorry
sorry-sorry when you ran that a second
time yes beautiful okay earth is going
on okay so it's conditioning the
distribution on the fact that x equals
seven
all right so my sister but then it's
raspberry 't oh yeah
that's no works definitely that's very
important and that's actually the next
item on the agenda is the random seed in
function is Randi not that that I'm not
worried it's how do we specify because
there's two ways you can either sample
or you can maximize a PDF get the mode
or all the communists in a way yes so
how do we specify that so it could be
with the third arguments by saying
sample actually it simplifies things a
lot if we just use one function because
when it was a learning the missing in
pewter we had kind of two method that
were conflicting there was a method by
the distribution and the method about do
you sample or do you find the mode and
that kind of conflicting so in terms of
design it was a bit hard if we learn the
distribution separately then then we can
just use the method of trying although
well come to that in a sec that's a
really scary thing that I had not
internalized okay that scared of I'm
scared of random things because I users
hate them I mean they then we get tech
support questions why did I get a
different answer
yeah why did I get a different answer
from this friend of mine and people have
a theory that you know it's like it's
like come
the the conflict between randomness and
science in the world so to speak you
know people will develop a theory oh I
got a different answer because it's
using the you know because my computer
is a different revision number or
something yeah I think it's really or
the fact that our CPU is a deterministic
when I was 2 P we probably stick will be
much more happy we could we can it's
important to kind of Caesar oh and it's
also important when you have two modes
so for example if I do in five point
five here has been trying fury at the
end of certainty in the world
sorry I'm just one point five so here is
in the four region but it might jump I
guess in the 1.5 which and if you
actually let's do the this with so why
why can't you generate from one of these
functions a conditional distribution
here I think we should at some points
and that should be it's kind of included
in the I mean it's allowed by the
current I mean it's not forbidden by the
current design so you'll be able to take
the land distribution so it will be post
twelve you know and do something like
there's effectively a conditioning of
the distribution all that so it may be
something like five point five this
would be a bad by the way of doing it
you should use missing to do it I think
it's a question of of I mean it's a
different it's a different case it's a
different case what are you doing here
is okay is it something like five point
five comma X yeah what it really is is a
scope struct yeah right so here's what I
think it is I think it's a um here if
you let me um um well it will be
something like five point five comma
yeah sometimes they are named so it can
be something like that okay finally what
I'm suggesting is that
this is a scoped conditioned
distribution right so in other words you
say yes condition distribution it's not
learn distribution it's just conditioned
distribution okay okay and then I'm
saying conditioned and did a of and then
a distribution like that distribution of
no no that thing of that distribution no
no that distribution not the conditioned
distribution of let's say open brace v
comma X okay now the beginning of
conditioned distribution put list X okay
so in other words what that's doing is
it's really what that is is actually
what you really want to say is
conditioned you yeah it's a it's a
distribution it's some kind of
distribution function right instead of a
conditioned distribution that really is
something more like a distribution
function I mean we could imagine doing
other things afterward on it so I think
it's true so by the way conditioned
conditioning is a big hole most people
think that they're no conditioning
because they know to be able to
conditioned on linear linear equations
or just values which is particularly
simple linear equations
but it needs to do a whole lot more the
range of what you can condition sorry
sorry sorry so Roger but do you have a
framework for how to represent condition
things you we avoided it until we got
more experience with it because the
problem is there's a certain kind of
thing that people think they don't want
but it's it turns out that it's way more
general that so basically you can
condition on any event so that means
that the things that you see textbook
wise you know conditional density and so
on but just conditioned on values so one
of just a gist you saw okay but that's
not nearly enough what you need you need
to be able to condition on any event
you're on an algebraic surface your your
honor okay so you really already have I
didn't remember that you had this
condition thing I now do remember it so
it's a probability and expectation take
conditioned okay and we have internally
something that's effectively a
conditioned distribution but to roll it
out we need there's a okay but wait
what's the corresponds between your
condition thing and what Etienne is
trying to do here do you understand that
correspondence or not yeah I'm just
worried that it gets rolled out here and
it's a design that's a dead end
no no no I'm not I'm not suggesting we
do roll it out here it's not needed yet
by a saw right I'm just asking the
question Roger if if the thing that
Etienne wants to do is it design
extensible from conditioned condition
this made you know to be and an inline
the condition typesetting construct okay
it's one shreds
yeah like that one so that's usually
what's use the vertical bar okay and we
do redesign something that's not just a
vertical bar because that mean so many
things it's not that much condition it's
more like this is simple the coding the
distribution distributed but what you
could do is to use probability or an
probability with some condition to find
for example a CDF for your you know
learn distribution conditions on some
value because you fixing one component
right so you can say you know y equals
five you know and then find the
probability that X is less and you know
something and it's gonna give you in FX
conditional CDF which they have the
clear conditional distribution in that
sense alright so listen I think there's
a sub discussion here about how to do
conditions but I'm just saying that
everybody thinks they know it but they
really don't you know you know they've
used cases to tear familiar with and
it's important to them so I'm not just
you know dissing that at all but they
don't know the full scope of it by a
long shot
okay attend can I have the screen back
yeah you know we just want to show you
that's when you take its plus five then
you have two modes anyway what do you
mean that was two modes the the mode is
the mode isn't it yeah well it's not
defined when there are multiple modes
right what the hell is it
okay so what you're telling me here okay
so two local modes
yes that we need to find a way to
specify do I want you know the most
likely value or or sample which when we
have wonderful we have a similar thing
with secrets predictably we had it which
was pretty hard classification active
classification it's the number three
where you have an association but if we
have only one function then that kind of
change the deal because learn
distribution will be trained separately
so now we are free to do whatever we
want either an argument is that's the
position number four which is crawl down
a little bit either an option method
option or three with another name that
we can do whatever it was okay so I
would recommend here so in our infer
missing values oh boy I hate generating
random stuff without telling people
that's what we're doing I mean one
possibility which I think you were
proposing is method arrow random to
wield a fourth by the way that is so
freaking horrifying well so long as if
you have random seeding and your random
seeding is one two three four why
because there will be there will be even
is that giving communists look okay
no go to sample otherwise you cannot
sample if it's random but when I'm
sitting wonderful for how do you you
have to change but you have to put
method random where I'm sitting and then
put what I don't remember in a retail so
wait a minute
I think the name infer missing values
does not suggest that you're gonna it's
like a random variate but none of these
names are suggestive that's the first
I've known that the surrounding function
it's it's actually dangerous let's say
you ever that's it
and you you you're infer by the most
likely value now I know that's you
compute the mean the mean will be
completely biased whereas if you sample
the mean will be non biased
also it really shows the users
uncertainty we have all these imputation
well then I would suggest I mean after
all this work on the name at least we
managed to get from the name we managed
to get down to one function let's
consider names for that function that
are things like sample you know that
involve things like I mean is there a
possible way to get so missing value
resample missing values I mean this that
this was something kind of collides in
my mind with what we have as a time
series for example when we actually the
term is to clear a sample the signal you
know so then it's deterministic you know
you know how you write this is a loser
yes we can't use the word resize result
or you can make it an argument may be a
bit more or stronger than an option if I
use a sample mode
I mean maybe all the names but like I
said he didn't it's not like I don't
know yeah I agree that in the name of
the function you know even clearer well
I mean but but the way you would expect
to use it is it the case that C random
variate it's very clear what you're
getting yeah but there
different name for random merit is
sampling
no I know
or simulate is another name for it just
quickly as some people you stimulate
yeah simulate missing values that would
tell you that it's simulating but
simulate doesn't simulate that's sort of
interesting that's sort of interesting I
agree that simulate missing values I
would expect that to produce something
it's it could perfectly well produce
something random and so would sample
missing values I don't know what that
means because sample means to me means
pick them out okay with it the other
meaning a sample is just like China I
know I know generate but then it's I
think if you avoid the confusion and
just use random sample then you know
that your creation it's random for many
peoples simulation means deterministic
to like I know that I know that I know
that that's the problem that I'm having
as well that's a very long name now yeah
it's horrible
we need to be ok let me give you a less
good sounding name randomized missing
values
you
I mean then it will be very clear it's
very clear I think people will think it
does nothing
yes but that's ok I mean the fact that
it doesn't do nothing but I agree ok so
a suggestion for our live stream is
synthesised missing values actually
actually we thought of a function that
would just do sampling you know from the
Italian instrument I want to call that
synthesized right yeah yeah which
there's also actually now now that we go
into the task goal route maybe this
could also about the power of line
distribution and it will be a sort of
task goal synthesized oh I don't know
yeah right well you just say random
variate of and then you do want to buy
it exactly so it's it's really to choice
having more functions or this test goal
thing well I think that some functions
look actually I think synthesized
missing values thank you to call Lang
for that suggestion that to me is the
most promising of the ones we've seen
here
it suggests that it is randomized in
some way it's it seems plausible that
will be randomized it suggests that it's
using something from the information
that's already there I like it I like it
too
yeah I think it's good wonderful um yeah
there we go and we make it work with a
nun distribution so okay if there's only
data it will learn from the data and if
there's a lone distribution and they try
to lose a longish revision and that's it
oh and the sample load thing yeah right
so then the method will be the default
method then we still have the problem
sorry I forgot we are not only learning
different separately right because if
you just put the data it will learn from
it so we need to both fit it by the
method of lung distribution and if it's
a sample imputation or mode imputation
okay all right um oh yes yes sorry on
our live stream brycie was actually the
person who suggested this um I can't
read the UM thank you they um okay so
wait a minute so you're saying that
there are two methods here yeah you
could have method multi normal let's say
this would be the you know one of the
simple methods for lending in
distribution and you may only want to
say do a sampling or do a sort of
optimization to find the mode I'm not so
far
it's a bit yeah it's mass clunky so the
two thing that I like the most is either
iving method for multi normal and so on
and then evaluation method which would
be an option we use in other places as
well because it's quite classic image
learning where you need to specify the
method on how to train and method on how
to evaluate we can explore the valuation
effort sounds awfully general for a lot
of things yeah sure but but maybe can be
using many other things I don't know
where else would you use evaluation
after don't think so actually classified
definitely would replace this this
association in to two things which
Association so go down go down
ego in the form method as suggestion can
have element evaluation it's called
evaluation strategy classification
method so classification method would
just be so by the way I mean clearly for
synthesized missing values the method
specification could perfectly well work
for exact same way as it does facts of
classification yes well it could say
evaluation strategy which is a good name
I think look I think this is what we
should do I think if it turns out people
are resetting this all the time great we
can have a more serious option but
otherwise evaluation strategy let's say
random sample a random sampling or um
what do we call it mode load finding
mode finding mode identification sounds
more fancy but um okay and this would be
learning method right learning method
yep
though method or no modeling method
distribution method I guess we had
classification method so it should be
distribution method why I don't know but
it's not the distribution it's it's I
mean it's it's really the learning
method it's going to turn until it's
going to be learn
look it's basically discharge yeah yeah
yeah Jordan to learning method yeah and
you don't like the arguments I don't
think we care if you tell me that it's
most sensible to do yeah random sampling
is the might by far the most sensible
thing to do
yeah I kind of agree with you I think it
people is just a formula for people to
get themselves tangled up by using you
know it's like like gum I can imagine
all sorts of because I mean when you say
I mean if you're filling in 25 missing
values you're filling in the mode of
that distribution the mode of the twenty
five dimensional distribution is a
difficult thing I do not even find it
yeah actually any time I will resort in
sampling many times and taking the most
likely of the samples of each sample
yeah I would sample like 100 times and
and get the one yeah okay fair enough
but let's say oh okay so but you're
right that that it's little biased and
and to find the mode it's harder for us
and it will bias so I'm actually happy
with this okay fine all right so
oh yeah this is the bigger well look
missing data we're agreeing what's
happening right now is it's missing data
um token yeah it's kind of lame because
it's um why is it missing data pattern
I'm wasn't it missing data pattern I
should be able to give any you know note
was the default on the
was call meeting that's correct but you
know token is not something we use very
much um on our live stream folks had
suggested missing handler a missing
substitution system but that isn't quite
right because it's not quite a handler
it is what constitutes as being missing
for purposes of
you
you
um let's see missing okay so what is
this doing this is I mean this is a
stupid name because it says is
misinterpreted all in a million ways um
and the problem is missing is missing
data token understandable or is that you
know first of all I mean missing token
is kind of absurd because that is like
it's missing where is it type thing
actually given the name of the function
missing value token would be better
wouldn't it
yes
you
okay missing value whoops I just filled
in yeah missing missing value pattern
but we don't usually use pattern to
represent just say anything when you
indicate all missing value what's that
yeah something more vague where we can
put patterns and all those things
because like indicator co-head what
we're gonna say because we could also
think that i'm not you know like like
these colors near not really a pattern
it's uh I don't know yes I understand
the name financially indicator that's
about a hundred of those right but but
let's imagine that we wanted missing
value look I could imagine this being
okay so let's try some things I mean
okay so look let's let's fill in some
things which might be useful here we
might say greater than I mean almost
this is missing value function
okay so one possibility is missing value
function okay so okay so another
possibility for that would be 90% of the
case would just be a token right so well
yeah it could be this though that will
be useful now alternatively um look I
can see missing value indicator very
often being you know negative values for
example you know your your machine is
reading you know I don't know pressure
of a something or other and it's
indication of an error as a negative
value again we'd go in discussion about
you know is it missing value or sense or
value in that case in that very case
right but way too
but I mean this is okay so one
possibility is a missing value function
because then we could just say negative
meaning its sum but then we also want I
have to say that I'm thinking missing
value pattern is the best one because
you know the default is underscore
missing but another possibility for
missing value is you know 99 might be
missing or minus one
now possibly if the data is huge you may
want some fancy way to process the
pattern values um I like this missing
value pattern objections from people I'm
good with that
um
comments on this because we're going to
end up wanting to use this in Statistics
functions at some point seems reasonable
to me let's just talk for a second about
import what does like for example when
you import a spreadsheet and there's
something that's just missing what does
it return
does anybody know I was looking at it we
have filled rows where we have rows with
less elements and then we have and
that's an option I think for CSV and
Excel then also we have empty field
option a string empty field that says
what to put in those empty fields
I see let me just look for one thing let
me just look at one so yeah something
called missing that I rooms that is a
string documented what is that case
maybe missing that are rules at
something of for semantic import
that is both specify what is missing and
how to what to replace oh so that's the
same thing we've been talking about
and the way the example of strings in
them well it's interesting I mean that's
closely related thing he has a bunch of
related missing that a method but what's
that an option in temporal data and
other functions to control how to
process missing data
so first of all missing data method
interpolation
so I guess I could be used rather learn
distribution I could be missing that I'm
a third learn distribution when using
yes absolutely nothing data method goes
to learn distribution and we could use
this option and classify as well and
other four I mean actually all machine
learning functions that would be nice
missing behavior okay listen we need a
separate discussion about missing values
um but his purposes missing value
pattern is okay and that we may want to
put that into things like in paint and
so on as well any objections here
I was also thinking delete missing
itself could take whatever option we
come up with here yes that's a good idea
you
that's an excellent idea that's a
minimal idea and an excellent idea
yeah absolutely should
I mean clearly one could always say
delete cases but this is a convenient
hazard
so you know one that we have now that
fills in missing this one deletes
missing so they kind of paired it is yes
do we need the word values in here
probably not makes a little clearer I
mean we could get rid of value in both
cases missing pattern yeah I hate that
so obscure you know what this is nice
this is this is clear if you see that in
a piece of code you know what the heck
it is and delete missing is deleting
yeah yeah delete missing is very
distinctly deleting missing this is fine
this is fine this is good okay well done
all right excellent result from
stream today thank you very much to
brycie for that suggestion that has
great help
um okay talk to you all soon I guess um
we're actually hold on a second I I was
saving this in some crazy place yes
Esther we know it's neutral Network
phone'll networks you want me to save it
and all that look framework section okay
will do
thanks okay see y'all bye